this season on stranger things
she misses her dad
we all do
[Music]
when you're different
sometimes
you feel like a mistake you're gay not
everything has a happy ending
you're not gonna die please don't hang
on i can't take it anymore
nobody moves on to the next phase until
we've all copied
nobody deviates from the plan no matter
what a few moments later if things here
start to go south i mean at all
you were born what
what i'm gonna snatch that diploma and
i'm gonna run like hell out of here
guys it was all alive holy crap that has
to be one of the best finales i've seen
in a long time stranger things season 4
volume 2 has just come to an end with
two action-packed episodes that would
make any hollywood blockbuster go i
can't compete with that there are a lot
of fun theories to explore like is this
actually the upside down what will is
actually hiding and has max's mind
disappeared to a different realm i have
answers to all those plus more i've even
left timestamps to all the topics i'll
be covering but before we get into it
make sure to like and subscribe it's the
only way i can support my pineapple
pizza addiction volume one left us with
the crazy reveal that eleven's friendly
orderly at hawkins lab was in fact the
murderous telekinetic youngster henry
creel unbeknownst to eleven she had
banished henry to this strange looking
realm in fact that's the exact word he
uses to describe it he never calls it
the upside down which you'd think he
would considering he knows everyone
calls it that he can go into people's
minds after all this place also looks
markedly different than the upside down
that we know it has this orange tinted
horizon and floating pieces of rock
remember that in episode 7 we learned
that the upside down is frozen in time
exactly november 6 1983 the day will
buyers went missing so are we to believe
that between september 8th 1979 the day
vecna was banished and november 6 1983
when time froze in the upside down that
vecna was somehow rebuilding hawkins
does time work differently here
something doesn't add up so right now
there are two theories either this place
is someplace different entirely or it's
what the upside down looked like before
vechna molded it into a place of his own
making he did say 11 and him could be
gods in their own worlds in which they
could create whatever they wanted just
like he drew spiders as a kid it seems
like he's able to manipulate this giant
swath of particles particles which were
also found in russia informed all those
creatures like the demogorgons demidogs
and demobats whatever or wherever this
place is it was avecna's ability to
manipulate the particles that allowed
him to survive and slowly regain his
strength it was only when eleven
inadvertently opened a gate to the
upside down in season one that vecna was
able to grab a foothold into the real
world all i needed was someone to open
the door
and he did that for me the only problem
is that every time one of these gates
would open eleven would close it right
back up so as he tells us in episode
nine vecna had to find a way to open his
own portals and the only way to do that
was by stealing eleven's ability to
create them he even says that he sought
her power remember these two things it
was 11 who unknowingly made several of
these portals in the first two seasons
and vecna has the ability to absorb
other people's abilities he takes
everything from his victims everything
they are and everything they ever will
be
their memories their abilities in season
three we saw how one of vecna's monsters
took a chunk out of eleven's leg both in
the cabin and later at starcourt mall
when eleven rips this creature out of
her leg this is the last time she's able
to use her powers until season four
perhaps this attack is what allowed
vecna to absorb her portal-making
ability which would explain why it
wasn't until season 4 that he begins to
attack which leads us to the four gates
we learn that in order for vecna to
begin his takeover of hawkins and
ultimately the world he needs 4 victims
he can easily control he does this by
manipulating their traumas by killing
them it allows him to create a portal
between his world and ours as dustin
says in episode 7 he's making a powerful
psychic connection with his victims a
connection powerful enough to rip a hole
in the fabric of time and space these
portals manifest wherever the victim is
killed so the four location victim pairs
we currently have are chrissy carmichael
in eddie munson's trailer fred benson on
a rural road patrick mckinney at the
bottom of the lake and max mayfield the
attic of the creel house it's never
really explained why exactly he needs
four gates or why he targets only teens
perhaps that will be something further
explored in season 5. all we really know
is that the number four matches with the
amount of times vecna's grandfather
clock chimes all these gates are open
and activated once max the final victim
dies creating what the media calls an
earthquake of unprecedented scale as
we'll see in the final scene this is a
hell of a lot more than an earthquake in
the hospital we learned that max had
been clinically dead for an entire
minute until a miracle occurred she came
back from the dead unfortunately blind
and with her arms and legs broken we do
know that eleven was with her in the
void at the time of her death and said
she's not going touching her chest we
see several flashbacks of happy memories
between her and max with the implication
being that she somehow revived max when
levin later visits max at the hospital
she tries to delve into her mind to
visit her similar to what she did with
her comatose mom in season two however
upon entering max is nowhere to be found
this could be because vecna has absorbed
her just like dr brenner said or it
could be because max has a power i'll
get into that in a different section but
there is hope however henry tells 11
that his victims aren't gone they're not
gone
eleven
they're still with me
[Music]
i imagine part of season 5 will include
11 having to save max from vecta's mind
potentially being able to restore her to
her body one scene i found particularly
odd was that of young max's memory
skateboarding like you could take this
scene out and it wouldn't change
anything in the story first it's not
that traumatic of a memory but it does
establish this new idea of memories
within memories it gave me total
inception vibes this is a really cool
concept and it makes me think this will
play a bigger role in season 5
considering it was added here we also
see lucas reading to max a book called
the talisman written by stephen king and
peter straub not only is this the next
series the duffer brothers plan to
produce after stranger things but the
plot is all about a character traversing
a parallel universe called the
territories sounds a lot like the upside
down but back to this healing power
which is never fully explained but i
imagine if vecna can use sad memories to
kill victims is it not possible that
happy memories can be used to revive
them furthermore if vecna can absorb
abilities ken 11 did she gain this
healing power from vecna or have her
abilities merely strengthened we know
vecna and eleven share this special
dichotomous bond one harnesses dark
memories while the other happy not only
were these two raised in hawken's lab
but they seem to be connected on a much
more visceral level especially since the
massacre at the lab in 79 they kind of
have this harry potter voldemort dynamic
with 11 choosing the sign of light and
vecna that of dark at the end of the
season we see this visually with the
beautiful multi-colored flowers on
eleventh side of the hill and the dead
and gray flowers on the other the ending
leaves us with an apocalyptic-like
future for hawkins vecna actually showed
nancy this future which calls into
question whether or not he can actually
predict it was he merely showing her
what would happen and he got lucky and
it came true or does he actually know
what the future may hold playing with
time is something the writers have kind
of hinted at throughout the season the
gates vechna open quote rip apart space
and time and we aren't sure if the realm
vecna operates in experiences time
differently i do want to play this line
from episode 1 about the relationship
between emotion and time which i found
really interesting time is funny like
that
emotions can make it speed up or slow
down we are all time travelers if you
think about it nancy elaborates to the
crew about this future vecna showder
some things have already happened which
vecna predicted like the dark cloud over
hawkins and the fires downtown however
we haven't seen this giant creature with
a gaping mouth or a flood of monsters
emerged just yet but most concerning is
that vecna showed nancy that her mom
sister and mike were all dead ted i
guess you're okay in an interview
showrunner ross duffer hinted that
season 5 may include a significant time
jump from season 4 especially
considering the stir season 4 caused
with the actors growing at a much faster
pace than the chronological timeline of
the show mike has been on an emotional
journey this season as strain was put on
his relationship with 11 when he
couldn't articulate his feelings for her
and tell her that he loves her his
self-doubt ended up getting in the way
of expressing his true feelings but but
what if after all this is over she
she doesn't need me anymore it's his
rousing speech in which he professes his
love to 11 that gives her the strength
to overpower vecna it's pretty much a
metaphor for love overcoming hate and
foreshadows how she will defeat vecna in
season 5. remember it was also 11's
loving memory of her mother that gave
her the strength to overpower henry back
in 1979. this also ties into eleven's
feeling that she is some sort of monster
what if i'm not good
what if i'm the monster but it's mike
who tells her she's a superhero and
gives her the strength to overcome her
own insecurities this superhero talk
along with dr brenner telling her in
order to defeat vecna she'll need to fly
leads me to believe that she will indeed
fly next season after all we have seen
her levitate people before why not
herself now i want to take a moment to
talk about will his struggle this season
is that he feels different there's an
emotional scene in the final episode
where his brother jonathan tells him
he'll love him even if he's different
because you're my brother
and i love you there is nothing in this
world okay i will ever change that the
simple explanation for this is that will
is hiding that he's gay we've seen him
turn down women's advances and countless
shots of him looking longingly at mike
but what if there's something more here
what if will is hiding something yet to
be known we know will has some sort of
connection with the upside down ever
since he went missing back in season one
at the end of season four we see
goosebumps appear on the back of his
neck when the ash cloud descends upon
hawkins he also tells mike that he can
feel vecna i can still remember what he
thinks and how he thinks and he's not
going to stop could will be controlled
by vecna either willingly or unwillingly
that's a bad pun this might explain why
11 didn't tell the others about her
healing power if she somehow knows will
is compromised there's a lot the show
can play with here our beloved guitar
hero eddie risked his life to save
hawkins and his friends but is this the
last time we'll see him i hate to say it
but most likely especially after the
emotional scene between dustin and his
uncle part of what made his character so
great was watching his character grow
from a coward that runs away to a hero
willing to face his fears to protect
those he loves he basically goes from
this
there is no shame in running to this i
didn't run away this time right part of
what makes us connected to this
character is seeing his flaw watching
him overcome it and turn out a better
person for it and that makes his death
all the more tragic the only way i could
see his character come back is a through
flashbacks or b if vecna has somehow
consumed him upon his death maybe his
soul could get released but even then
there's no body for it to go back to
plus it's probably too long for 11 to
try any sort of resurrection like eddie
lucas has gone on his own journey this
season believing that hanging out with
jason and the jocks that he can shake
off this image of him being one of the
weird kids i'm tired of girls laughing
at us i'm tired of feeling like a loser
we came to high school wanting things to
be different right lucas needs to
realize it's better to be yourself than
try to fit in just to be popular he'll
complete his journey by saying this to
jason i thought i wanted to be like you
but it turns out
he's just a raging psychopath speaking
of not normal how about that awkward
love triangle between steve nancy and
jonathan things are kind of up in the
air as to what's really going on with
jonathan moving to california at the end
of season three it put him and nancy in
a long distance relationship allowing
for steve who's kind of been hooking up
with all sorts of women but not finding
any fulfillment in it in a situation to
discover if there's still feelings for
her jonathan hasn't told nancy that he
doesn't want to go to college because if
he told her that he says she would
follow him not go to college herself and
then grow to resent him this this huge
knot of resentment would build
like like some cancer he doesn't want to
see their relationship turn into what
happened to his divorced parents
meanwhile we have steve coming to terms
with his true feelings for nancy without
any hesitation it was nancy who dove in
after him when he was dragged through
the lake something eddie calls one
ambiguous sign of true love steve will
later tell nancy that his perfect dream
of owning a winnebago and having six
kids includes her but before he can go
any further they're interrupted by robin
so this whole love triangle thing is
still a big mess considering jonathan
and nancy spent almost no time together
this season my bet is that nancy will go
with steve which may be a bit awkward
considering john and nancy are dating in
real life bonus points if you caught
nancy and john holding hands in the
final scene speaking of love what about
robin and vicky at the beginning of the
season robin questions whether or not
her bandmate vicki feels the same way
about women that she does and it's steve
who's quick to note that when vicki
returned fast times at ridgemont high it
was paused during the famous booby scene
i like boobies you like boobies
vicky likes boobies robin's dream of
being with vicki are crushed when she
sees she has a boyfriend however when
they chat at the shelter there is hope
vicky has broken up with him and there
definitely is some awkward chemistry as
they make pb and j sandwiches a new
element brought into this season is the
piggyback i piggybacked from a pizza
dough freezer it refers to 11 being able
to travel into another person's memory
while vecna has control over it she is
essentially piggybacking it when vecna
connects into someone's memory his
physical body enters this trance-like
state 11 theorizes that she can do this
too and can simultaneously enter the
same memory this is how vechna and 11
are able to interact even though they're
thousands of miles apart it's a really
cool new element that i hope will be
utilized in season 5. one thing that
still hasn't been explained is how max
somehow infiltrated vector's mind in
episode 4. max tells nancy that when she
arrived at his lair that vecna seemed
surprised like he didn't want her there
maybe you infiltrated his mind he
invaded your mind right is it that big
of a leap to suggest you somehow wound
up in his could max unknowingly have an
ability to travel into other people's
minds dreams or memories this might
explain why 11 couldn't find her while
visiting in the hospital it could be a
cool dynamic in season 5 if max could
visit the other kids via their dreams or
memories but it's dusty who says
something really interesting here that's
never really been mentioned again what
if you somehow unlocked a back door to
vector's world a backdoor could come in
really handy for our characters in
bringing vecna down with hawkins on its
way to destruction it looks like the u.s
military will be on its way after all
nancy did say she saw lots of dead
soldiers in her vision of the future the
last we saw of colonel jack sullivan was
in the nevada desert so expect him to
make a return in his quest for 11.
remember that he believes 11 to be
responsible for all this mess and only
by killing her can this apocalyptic
threat be neutralized and there are a
ton of other loose threads like murray
yuri dimitri and dr owens who we have no
idea if we'll see again my bet is that
murray will definitely be back and what
will happen between 11 and hopper
they'll probably move in with joyce but
where it looks like hawkins is
evacuating the great thing about this
season's ending is it really felt it
closed one chapter of the series yet
opened a whole new world of
possibilities literally they opened the
world but now i leave the floor open to
you what are your thoughts and theories
for season five i want to hear them in
the comments below thanks for watching
everyone be sure to like and subscribe
and you can follow me on twitter and
instagram thingstoryt until next time
remember there will be no more
retreating